lennon will punt it from the 24 dimitri  stanley  is hovering around his own 25.  [Applause]  this one fielded at the 20. it's rice  with the room brendon rice makes  one man miss brandon rice  heading into the end zone touchdown  colorado  [Applause]  as proud as you can possibly be right  now he has to retreat  and he takes it and then look this hole  is wide open he doesn't have to make too  many cuts until right here  makes the punter miss and then he turns  on the jets great speed from brendan  rice 6-3 205.  first down to 10 at the 39. near side  ball is caught it's rice and rice still  running wow look at this again  brendon rice with a touchdown  first it was an 81-yard return